[موسيقى] على بعد
حوالي ساعة بالسيارة خارج المدينة
في ساو جوزيه دوس كامبوس ساو باولو هو
المقر الرئيسي لشركة Umbra air ، كل
ثانية لدينا طائرة Embraer
تقلع من أي جزء من مرمى
Walter Pinto jr.  هو نائب
رئيس الدفاع والأمن في شركة Embraer ،
حيث تقوم الشركة بتطوير
وتصنيع العديد من
طائراتها واختبارها. Embraer هي ثالث أكبر
شركة لتصنيع الطائرات ، لذلك لدينا
أعمال في الطائرات التجارية في طائرات رجال
الأعمال وأيضًا في الطائرات العسكرية ، إنها
الأخيرة العسكرية  الطائرات التي
تصدرت عناوين الصحف والتاريخ في Embraer
اليوم ، تم تطوير KC 390 بالشراكة
مع القوات الجوية البرازيلية ، وهي
أكبر طائرة صنعتها الشركة التي يبلغ عمرها 50
عامًا فرانسيسكو غوميز نيتو.
الحديث عن الابتكار ، أعتقد أن
هذه إحدى نقاط القوة في أومبريا
التي استثمرت كثيرًا في السنوات الماضية
في بيئة الابتكار هذه ،
لدينا اتفاقيات مع
الكثير من الجامعات ومراكز الأبحاث
في البرازيل في الخارج ، ثم يقول البعض إن
هندستنا هي  أقوى أصولنا
في الشركة ولدينا ما يقرب من 6000
مهندس وأعتقد أن معظمهم
هم ج  من الجامعات البرازيلية
، ساعد هذا في تحويل
ولاية ساو باولو إلى أكبر مركز طيران في أمريكا اللاتينية
يمثل
95 بالمائة من
موظفي البرازيل في هذا القطاع